in this video i'm gonna break down one
of the stories that impacted my life the
most and hopefully how you can learn
from it so i wasn't that great of a
person when i graduated high school i
think i was really self-centered it was
always about me and what everyone could
do for me everything i wanted was just
like respect and status and maybe that
hasn't changed i've just gotten better
at it i don't know i want to share with
you a conversation that changed my life
if you don't know i am my name is
ashmosey own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies of 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you this
particular story was after my first
semester of college i went to an all guy
school in high school and i went to
vanderbilt for my undergrad and i had
acquired a pretty bad reputation in my
opinion in high school by being kind of
uh promiscuous for lack of utter term i
you know i was known as a womanizer and
i just didn't generally have a very good
reputation at least one that i wasn't
proud of and so when i went to college i
was like okay it's my chance to start
fresh and it's a much bigger school so
you know
my transgressions won't be as known
because there's way more people and the
first you know three months of my
college career i did everything that i
was doing in high school on steroids i
did more of everything i drank more i
went out more i ended up having a one i
think a one nine gpa going inside i
basically had these report cards from
my teachers that were like halfway
through the first semester that were
sent home that were like your son is
failing basically every class
and so my dad called me up and was like
if you're gonna do this like you can do
this it's here for free and not do this
at college right
and so i went home and i was like how do
i get these people to stop talking all
the smack like there was this thing back
in the day called juicy campus which was
like a gossip form it ended up getting
shut down because there was so much hate
on it but there was like this massive
massive threat about me and how i was
just like a total womanizer and all the
stuff i felt horrible you know i mean
you can imagine like the younger version
of yourself that's really sensitive to
like what everyone says about you and so
i i just went to my dad and i was like
how do i change what they're saying how
do i get them to say good things and it
sounds [ __ ] to say this now but what
he said to me changed my life
and he looked at me in the eyes and he
was like
why are you trying to change people's
perception of you when you can just
change who you are and let their
perceptions catch up the only way you're
going to change your reputation is by
being different he's like you need to
stop being this person that does all
these things and your reputation will
catch up and even if it doesn't you'll
always know i and honestly it barely
scratched the surface because my ego was
so high and i was like no i just have to
think of a better way to like market
myself but i ended up knowing that he
was very serious about the threat of
pulling me out of school if i didn't get
my grades up and so what i ended up
doing for the next half of the semester
of my first semester freshman year is i
didn't go out at all i didn't drink
anymore i really didn't like hang out
with girls at all and all i did was
study and i was able to pull my it might
have been 1-2 it was very low up to a
3.2 for the semester which basically
meant i got an a on everything from that
point for the rest of the semester and
so when i went back home he was like
well now you know you can do it and so
we should always expect that that is
what you're going to get from here on
out and it also kind of proved it to
myself too i was like i guess i can do
this and you know what happened is after
i started switching that way
people still thought of me as a [ __ ]
and i still had to deal with that it
took like two years to really reverse
the reputation that i had acquired in
the first three months i think during
that period of time i grew an
appreciation for how easy it is
especially in first impressions to set
the wrong one and how hard it is to
overcome a negative impression and my
reputation overall the realization i had
was there's too many people that you're
interacting with in the world to try and
curate reputation
the only way to change your reputation
is to change who you are reputation is
fundamentally just what people say about
you to your face and behind your back
i'm not saying that you need to care
about what everyone else thinks that's
not really the point of this it's much
more if one person says you're an
[ __ ] whatever if every person you
know says you're an [ __ ] like you
might be an [ __ ] and so if you have
one of those situations where you feel
like the proof or the evidence is
overwhelming and you might even believe
it then it's probably you i think that
for me
getting out of the whole like i can
control this and try and curate what
people think about me and transitioning
to be like at the end of the day i'm the
only person who knows who i am and i
don't like who i am and just saying like
well how can i get to a point where i
would like me even if everyone else
hated me how can i like me when i
started operating from that place it
really changed my life because then i
started thinking like what version of me
do i want to be and what does that guy
do well that guy studies really hard and
that guy works out really hard and that
guy's a really good friend he's always
respectful doesn't have an ego and it
took me a long time but i still work on
this stuff you know even i'm not saying
i'm done by any any search imagination
but i think that if you can simply shift
the perspective of like i'm going to try
and appear this way to like i want to be
this way if it just so happens to get
captured great and if it doesn't
great and there's this this quote by
epictetus that i'm probably gonna
butcher but he says if you need someone
else to
tell you something about yourself you
are out of integrity because you can
always be your own witness i think that
that's a great point to wrap the this
little video lesson up with because that
piece strikes to the core of everything
which is we are our own witnesses and if
we want to change our reputation we need
to change our reputation with ourselves
first and then eventually it will
reflect in the world and this has just
been very telling for me because like
more and more people recognize me every
day when i'm walking around and i'm like
jeez like i don't have any room for
having a bad day like if i'm out to
dinner and like i'm just like not
concentrating and i'm short with the
waiter and the waiter recognizes me then
you know he's like this guy's an [ __ ]
or whatever and so i guess in some ways
it's like you can pretend like you're
famous because you are to yourself and
so i will leave you with that mozzie
nation if you're new to the channel
welcome lots of love and i'll see you
guys next video bye